but
objectivism objectivism so and and so
she developed it for a novel she spent
the latter part of her life after the
publication of atlas shark really
articulating her philosophy so that's
what she did she
applied it to politics to life to gender
to all these issues
from 1957 until she died in 1982 so the
objectivism was born
out of the later parts of atlas shrugged
yes definitely
it was there all the time but it it was
fleshed out during the latter part of
alex shugden and articulated for the
next 20 years so what is
objectivism subjectivism so there are
five branches in philosophy and it and
so i'm going to
just go through the branches she starts
with you start with metaphysics the
nature of reality
and objectivism argues that reality is
what it is it's kind of
uh goes hawkins back to aristotle of
identity a
is a you can wish it to be b but wishes
do not make something real
reality is what it is and it is the
primary
and it was it's it's not it's not
manipulated directed by consciousness
consciousness
is there to uh you know to observe to
to give us information about reality
that is the purpose of consciousness
it is the nature of it so in metaphysics
existence exists it it the law of
identity
the law of causality things are you know
the things
act based on their nature not randomly
not arbitrarily
based on their nature and then we have
the tool to know
reality this is epistemology the theory
of knowledge
a tool to know reality is reason it's
our senses and our capacity to integrate
the information we get from our senses
and to integrate it into new knowledge
and to conceptualize it
and uh and and that is uniquely human um
uh we don't we don't know the truth
from revelation we don't know
truth from our emotions our emotions are
interesting our emotions tell us
something about ourselves
but our emotions are not tools of
cognition they don't tell us the truth
about what's
out there about what's in reality
so reason is a means of knowledge and
therefore meet reason is not means of
survival
only individuals reason just in the same
way that only individuals can eat
we don't have a collective stomach
nobody can eat for me
and therefore nobody can think for me i
we don't have a collective mind
there's no collective consciousness none
it's it's bizarre that people talk about
these
collectivized aspects of the mind they
don't talk about collective
feats and collective stomachs and
collective things but
so we all think for ourselves and it is
our
fundamental basic responsibility to live
our lives
to live to choose once we choose to live
to live
our lives to the best of our ability
so in morality she is an egoist she
believes that the purpose of morality is
to provide you with a code of values and
virtues
to guide your life for the purpose of
your own
success your own survival your own
thriving your own happiness
happiness is the moral purpose of your
life
the purpose of morality is to guide you
towards a happy life
your own happiness your own happiness
absolutely your own happiness
so she rejects the idea that she should
live for other people that you should
live
for the purpose of other people's
happiness your purpose is not to make
them happier to make them anything your
purpose is your own happiness
but she also rejects the idea that you
could argue maybe
the chain idea of you should use other
people
for your own purposes right so every
person
is an end in himself every person's
moral responsibility is their own
happiness
and you shouldn't use other people for
your own you shouldn't exploit other
people for your own happiness
and you shouldn't be allow yourself to
be exploited for other people every
individual is responsible for themselves
and what is it that allows us to be
happy what is it that facilitates
um human flourishing human success
human survival well it's the use of our
minds right because it goes back to
reason
and what does a reason require in order
to
to be successful in order to to work
effectively it requires freedom
so the enemy of reason the enemy of
reason is force
the enemy of reason is coercion the
enemy of reason is
authority right the catholic church
doing what they did to galileo right
that restricts
galileo's thinking right when he's in a
house arrest is he going to come up with
a new theory he's going to discover new
truths
no it it it's the punishment is too
you know it's too dangerous so force
coercion
um are enemies of reason
and what reason needs is to be free
to to think to to discover to innovate
to break
out of convention
so we need to create an environment in
which individuals are free to reason to
free to think
and to do that we we come up with a
concept historically we've come up with
a concept of individual rights
individual rights define the scope of
define the fact that we should be left
alone free to pursue
our values using our reason free of what
free of course and force authority
and that the job of government is to
make sure that we are free
the whole point of government the whole
point of when we come in a social
context
the whole point of establishing a
government in that context is
to secure that freedom
it's to make sure that i don't use
cursion on you
the government is supposed to stop me
supposed to intervene before i can do
that or if i've already done it
to prevent me from doing it again
so the purpose of government is to
protect our freedom to think and to act
based on our thoughts
it's to leave individuals free to pursue
their values to pursue their happiness
to pursue their rational thought
and to be left alone to do it and so she
rejects
socialism which which basically assumes
some kind of collective goal assumes the
sacrifice of the individual to the group
assumes that your moral purpose in life
is the well-being of other people rather
than your own
uh and and she rejects all form of
statism
all form of government uh that is
you know overly uh that that is involved
in any aspect other than to protect us
from forced coercion authority uh and
she rejects
anarchy and we can talk about that i i i
i think you had a question and a list of
questions you sent me about anarchy so
sure
and i'm happy to talk to you like alice
about anarchy so yes i don't know if
you're familiar with him
yes i'm familiar with him so so yeah so
she would completely reject anarchy
anarchy is completely inconsistent with
their point of view and we can talk
about why if you want
so there's some perfect place where
freedom is maximized so systems of
government and
absolutely and she thought that the
american system of government came close
in its idea obviously founded with
original sin with the sin
of slavery but in its conception the
declaration of dependence is about as
perfect a political document as one
could write
i think the greatest political document
in human history but really articulated
almost perfectly
um and and beautifully and the american
system government with the chexist
balances
balances which is with its emphasis on
individual rights with its emphasis on
freedom
with its emphasis on leading leaving
individuals free to pursue their
happiness
an explicit recognition of happiness as
a goal
individual happiness it was the model it
it wasn't perfect
a lot of problems to a large extent
because the founders had mixed
philosophical premises
so so there were there were alien um uh
premises introduced into the founding of
the country slavery obviously being the
biggest problem
uh but it was close and
we need to build on that to create an
ideal political system
that will yes maximize
the freedom of individuals to do exactly
this um
and then of course she had so that's
kind of uh that's
the manifestation of this individualism
in the political realm
and she had a theory of art she had a
theory of aesthetics which is the fifth
branch of
of she have metaphysics epistemology
ethics
and politics and the fifth branch is
aesthetics and she viewed art
as an essential human need
a fuel for the human spirit and that
just like
any human need it had certain principles
that it had to abide by
that is just like there's nutrition
right so some food is good for you and
some food is bad for you some food
some stuff is poison she believed the
same is true of arts that art had an
identity
which is very controversial today right
if you you know today it's if you put a
frame around it it is art right if you
put a unil
in a urinal in a in a museum it becomes
art which he thought was
it was evil and and and ludicrous and
she rejected completely
uh that art had an identity and that it
served a certain function
that human beings needed it and if it
didn't have
not only did it have have the identity
but that function was served well by
some art
and poorly by other art um and then
there's a whole realm of stuff that's
not art
basically all of all of what today is
considered modern art
she would consider as not being art you
know splashing paint on a canvas
not art so
she had very clear ideas
she articulated them not
so i would say not in conventional
philosophical form
so she didn't write philosophical essays
using
the philosopher's language it's white
partially white i think philosophers
have never taken it seriously
they're actually accessible to us we can
actually
read them and she integrates the
philosophy in what i think are amazing
ways with psychology
with history with economics with
politics with what's going on in the
world
and she has dozens and dozens and dozens
of essays that she
she wrote many of them were aggregated
into books uh
i particularly recommend books like uh
the virtue of selfishness capitalism the
unknown ideal
uh and and uh philosophy who needs it
and you know it's it's a i think it's a
it's a it's a beautiful philosophy
uh you know i know you're big on love i
think it's the philosophy of love
we can talk about that essentially it's
about love that's what the philosophy is
all about and when it apply in terms of
it's applying to self
um and uh you know i i think it's sad
that so few
so few people read it and so few
intellectuals
take it seriously and are willing to
engage with it let me
ask that was incredible but after that
beautiful whirlwind
overview let me ask the most shallow of
questions which is
the name objectivism
of where like how should people think
about
the name being rooted why not
individualism what what are the options
if we're like had a branding meeting
right now sure so she actually had a
branding meeting
so she she did this she went through the
exercise the objectives were i do not
think i don't know
all the details but i don't think
objectivism was the first
name she came with the problem was that
the other names were taken
and they were not positive implications
so for example rationalism could have
been a good word because
she's an advocate of rational thought or
reasonism but reasonism
sounds weird right the ism because of
too many s's i guess
rationalism but it was already a
philosophy and it was a philosophy
inconsistent with herbs
because it was it was a it was a what
she considered a false
view of reason of rationality um
reality-ism you know just doesn't work
so she came on objectivism and i think
actually
it it it's a great word it's a great
name because
it it's it has two aspects to it and
this is a unique view of what
objectivity actually means in
objectivism
in objectivity is the idea of an
independent reality
there is truth there's actually
something out there that we
and then there's the wall of
consciousness
right there is the role of figuring out
the truth
the truth doesn't just hit you
the truth is not in the thing
you have to discover it it's that it's
that
a consciousness applied to
that's what objectivity is right it's
you
discovering the truth in reality it's
your consciousness
it's interacting and thereby opposing
the individual in that sense
and only the individual could do now the
problem with individualism
is it would have made the philosophy to
political
right and she always said so she said
she said i'm an advocate of capitalism
because i'm really an advocate for
rational egoism
but i'm irrational who i am advocate for
really because i'm an advocate for
reason so she viewed the essential of
her philosophy
as being this uh reason and her
her particular view of reason she has a
whole book she has a book called
uh introduction to objectivist
epistemology which i encourage any
scientist
mathematician anybody interested in
science to read because it is
a tuitive force on on on in a sense the
the
what it means to hold concepts and what
it means
to discover new discoveries and to use
to use concepts and how we use concepts
and she has a theory
of concepts that is completely new
that is completely revolutionary and i
think is essential for the philosophy of
science
and therefore ultimately for the more
abstract we get with scientific
discoveries
the easier it is to detach them from
reality
and to detach them from truth the easy
it is to be inside our heads
instead of about what's real
and they're probably examples from
monophysics that fit that
and i think what she teaches in the book
is how to ground your concepts and how
to bring them
into grounding in reality so
introduction to objectives to cosmology
note that it's only an introduction
because one of the things she realized
one of the things that i think a lot of
her critics
don't give enough credit for is the
philosophy is
there's no end right it's always growing
they're always new discoveries there's
always it's
it you know it's like science there's
always new things and and there's
a ton of work to do in in philosophy
uh and particularly in epistemology in
the theory of knowledge that she was
actually
giving you interest in mathematics she
was she actually saw
a lot of parallels between math and
concept formation
and she was actually you know in the
years before she died
she was taking private lessons in
mathematics in algebra
and calculus because she believed that
there was real
insight in understanding algebra in
calculus to
um philosophy into epistemology
and and she also was very interested in
neuroscience because she believed that
that had a lot to tell us
about epistemology but also about music
therefore about aesthetics so
i mean she recognized the importance of
all these different fields and how in
the beauty of philosophy is it should be
integrating all of them
and one of the sad things about the
world in which we live is again we view
these things as silos
we don't view them as integrating we
don't have teams of people from
different
arena you know different fields you know
discovering things we we
we become like ants specialized so she
was definitely
like that and she was constantly curious
constantly interested in in new
discoveries and new ideas and and how
this
could expand the scope of her philosophy
and application of her philosophy
you